pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des Bouches-du-Rhône membre du
groupe les républicains on va revenir
évidemment sur l'actualité du côté de
Marseille actualité chargée mais d'abord
un mot on l'a vu dans le journal
Elisabeth Bank qui est recevait hier les
chefs de partie les chefs de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était à Matignon
cette rencontre dont Olivier marlex le
patron des députés LR il demande une
conférence des prix de l'énergie est-ce
que l'État doit aider les Français face
à la hausse des prix du carburant
écoutez je sais pas s'il faut une
conférence en tout cas il faut il faut
des mesures immédiates le prix à la
pompe affiche les deux euros en euros 99
c'est c'est le pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui est en jeu et je pense
qu'il faut un peu arrêter avec ces
réunions Tupperware de Madame borne ou
monsieur Macron qui
amène à rien cette à l'exécutif de
prendre ses mesures il y a deux mesures
à prendre rapidement une baisse de la
fiscalité sur les carburants pour
avoir un poumon de 20 à 30 centimes
d'euros ce qui a été fait l'année
dernière doit être reconduit et puis la
deuxième chose il faut être aussi l'état
qui doit prendre sa part ou c'est les
entreprises parce que républicains
de baisser la dépense publique est-ce
que c'est pas contradictoire non c'est
pas contradictoire puisque l'inflation a
emmagasiné des milliards d'euros de
recettes supplémentaires par rapport au
prévisionnel l'idée étant de répartir
l'effort sur les Français et également
sur la réduction de la dette publique en
fait on demande surtout qu'on dépense
mieux parce que je peux vous mettre
derrière des chiffres comme la fraude
fiscale ou la fraude sociale où ce sont
des milliards d'euros qui sont dépensés
inutilement détournés donc encore une
fois une mesure directe pour faire
baisser les prix à la pompe et puis
surtout s'interroger sur le marché de
l'énergie à l'échelle européenne des
pays en sont sortis et quand vous voyez
nos voisins affichés des prix largement
inférieur à ceux qu'on a fait on affiche
en France notamment pour pour les
carburants il y a des choses à on doit
s'interroger sur sur ces choses là et
puis dernier point sur l'énergie on doit
pas te payer en fait les Français ne
doivent pas payer la facture je dirais
de Hollande Macron sur le
désinvestissement du nucléaire on en
serait pas là si on avait 14 réacteurs
nucléaires qui ont été démantelés et qui
ne sont plus en fonctionnement
aujourd'hui l'autre actualité c'est
l'Élysée qui a donc annoncé hier
qu'Emmanuel Macron insisterait bien à la
messe du pape ce sera samedi prochain au
stade Vélodrome chez vous à Marseille
est-ce que ça vous choque un président
un système messe non écoutez arrêtons
l'hypocrisie j'allais dire vous savez la
France est un pays au racine
judéo-chrétienne il faut voir faut voir
la chose de manière positive vous savez
ça fait 500 ans que Marseille n'a pas
reçu un pape il y a une certaine fierté
d'ailleurs des Marseillais par rapport à
cette devenu une certaine ébullition
d'ailleurs donc c'est cela qu'il faut
voir
la laïcité non parce que les mêmes qui
dénoncent cette fameuse entrave à la
laïcité peuvent fêter le jeune musulman
le jeune musulman effectivement
effectivement l'Aïd notamment la mairie
de Paris donc arrêtons cette forme
d'hypocrisie c'est le dialogue avec tout
les cultes que l'on soit chrétiens
musulman juif c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir sur laïcité le pape qui devrait
évidemment profiter de sa visite à
Marseille pour parler d'immigration le
sujet est revenu sur la table en cette
rentrée notamment avec cette tribune qui
a été publiée cette semaine tribune
qu'au signée de parlementaire de la
majorité présidentielle et de
parlementaires de la gauche est-ce que
vous fermez la porte à cette mesure de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
d'ailleurs d'abord ce que j'observe
quand même c'est la division de la
macronie sur sur ce sujet avec une
pression de l'élevegoche et cette
tribune signée avec avec la nupes pour
faire fléchir le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur sur ce sujet
deux choses il y a un principe de
réalité quand même notamment dans des
zones touristiques il y a des
restaurateurs des hôteliers même le BTP
qui ont besoin de main d'oeuvre et une
main d'oeuvre dans l'urgence parce que
ils mettent en péril leur activité et ça
faut bel et bien le prendre en compte
est-ce que c'est la bonne mesure
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de garde-fou pour
nous assurer que ça sera pas un appel
d'air cette mesure l'article 3 et
l'article 4 il faudra qu'on discute avec
le mini l'intérieur parce que
c'est pas une ligne rouge vous pouvez
trouver un compromis sur cette mesure
ça appartiendra déjà on va on va
attendre le texte final puisque pour
l'heure nous l'avons pas on a eu une
première lecture il y a quelques mois de
cela d'un texte est-ce que ça sera la
même mouture
on verra le si le 6 novembre derrière
quand même sur le sujet de l'immigration
les LR avait proposé deux textes un
texte constitutionnel et un texte loi
ordinaire je pense que sur ce sujet là
quand on regarde ce qui se passe à
Lampedusa il faudra consulter les
Français c'est un c'est un enjeu majeur
du 21e siècle et on ne peut pas faire
sans les Français sans la souveraineté
vous comme question en français ah non
le référence serait sur le projet de loi
constitutionnel en disant est-ce qu'on
reprend notre destin en main par la
méthode de quota par pays par métier
est-ce que par rapport à l'intérêt
supérieur du pays et l'article 55 sans
rentrer dans le détail mais je pense
qu'il doit y avoir un débat pour de
prendre en main notre destin en matière
de flux migratoire vous savez ce qui se
passe à l'empedisa et fort inquiétant et
puis on est à l'aube d'une vague de de
d'immigration qu'on doit qu'on doit
contrôler ça pose aussi la question du
co-développement on en parle pas assez
mais ces pays notamment africains il
faut pouvoir aussi les les aider de
manière à ce qu'il se développe et que
éviter ces vagues migratoires parce
qu'on peut très bien comprendre que
certains soient dans la détresse du coup
vous souhaitez un compromis sur ce texte
est-ce que vous dites coûte que coûte il
faut qu'on arrive à une loyers il faut
il y a des bonnes mesures dans ce texte
donc effectivement il y a des mesures
qu'on porte depuis des années le retour
de de la double peine par exemple donc
il va falloir qu'on trouve un compromis
mais en tout état de cause vous savez
aujourd'hui la faiblesse allait chez la
macronie on voit bien que l'aile gauche
ne veut pas de ce texte ou insiste pour
gaucher le texte que Gérald Darmanin à
mon sens ne veut absolument pas vous
comprenez les députés à l'air qui font
planer la menace d'un 49-3
on n'est pas dans le même logique que il
y a quelques mois à la sortie de la
réforme des retraites on ne parle plus
de dissolution le président de la
République n'a pas pour objectif de
dissoudre maintenant donc forcément la
motion
c'est un sujet que vous portez vous le
dites depuis des années est-ce que ça
crédit si dorénavant le texte final ne
correspond pas à nos objectifs et aux
deux textes ou en tout cas ou mesure que
nous portons avec ces deux textes de loi
ordinaire et de loi constitutionnelle
forcément je pense qu'il faudra
s'interroger d'autant plus que je pense
que Madame borne n'est pas n'est plus en
capacité de faire l'alliance avec avec
la droite on va y revenir évidemment sur
les relations entre LR et la majorité on
va aller à Marseille chez vous retrouver
les ho purgate bonjour Léo merci
beaucoup d'être avec vous président et
directeur éditorial du Journal La
Marseillaise allez on est ravis de vous
recevoir sur plateau alors on revient
évidemment sur l'actualité du côté de
Marseille la triste actualité du côté de
Marseille et cette agression antisémite
un acte qui on l'imagine choque la ville
bien sûr un acte qui évidemment est
effroyable un jeune homme agressé en
pleine rue par un chauffard qui tente de
le renverser le trade de sa juif le
détrousses à l'aide d'un complice c'est
évidemment effroyable pour toute la
ville singulièrement pour un journal
comme le nôtre qui est issu de la
résistance alors je voulais demander au
sénateur Stéphane Le Rue dullier comment
lui il envisage de combattre la haine
quel que soit sa forme d'où qu'elles
viennent alors même que on le voit dans
le débat public et bien
l'exacerbation des questions d'identité
provoque ces tensions de plus en plus
importantes dans la société
d'abord c'est un drame
abject vous l'avez dit avec une
recrudescence des actes antisémites en
il est clair que il y a plusieurs
phénomènes à cela si je pense que
l'arsenal législatif est suffisant quand
on regarde le cas législatif il y a de
quoi punir assez sévèrement les auteurs
de ses actes mais vous avez raison il y
a une responsabilité de la part des
politiques
à apaiser le débat sur certains certains
thèmes vous parlez de l'identité il faut
aussi apaiser le débat et le dialogue
des cultures puisqu'on se rend compte
parfois que il est impossible dans
certains secteurs ou dans certains
quartiers d'enseignés parfois la Shoah
et ça c'est l'histoire vous l'avez
rappelé c'est l'histoire qui permet de
prendre conscience que ces actes ont
amené à une guerre la plus meurtrière au
monde et si on n'enseigne pas ça ça veut
dire qu'on perd cette forme de pédagogie
et qu'on banalise ses actes et donc sur
deux aspects puis après le dernier point
ça je les remarqué aussi attention à ne
pas faire un transfuge du conflit
israéluia palestinien en France ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas l'objet je pense
et nous confondons pas l'antisionisme et
l'antisémitisme
vous avez une autre question on regarde
notre une
non on va regarder notre une qui qui
prolonge d'ailleurs cette question avec
et bien cette haine qui sur le terrain
politique avance nous avons un dossier
sur la rentrée de l'extrême droite qui
bien qu'elle ait souhaité se normaliser
dans les institutions et bien devient de
plus en plus importantes et avec des
formes multiples notamment en Vaucluse
où elle est très implantée et où le RN
fera sa rentrée à partir de ce soir où
il y a un rassemblement qui est appelé
par les syndicats également les
organisations progressistes pour ne pas
banaliser les idées qu'ils portent la
reine qui est effectivement dans le
Vaucluse aujourd'hui puis qui sera à
Beaucaire ce weekend c'est à la Une de
La Marseillaise le chancre qui abîme le
sud c'est à la ligne de votre journal
merci beaucoup merci Léo d'avoir été
avec nous pour rester sur à Marseille
évidemment l'actualité c'est aussi le
trafic de drogue et on a vu cette jeune
femme tuée il y a quelques jours alors
qu'elle se trouvait chez elle tuée par
des tirs à l'aveugle près d'un point de
ville Gérald Darmanin est venu à
Marseille sa visite était prévu il a
confirmé qu'une unité de CRS serait
déployée en novembre il y a les moyens
en tout cas l'État met les moyens pour
lutter contre le trafic de drogue à
Marseille mais alors que faire pour que
ça marche
incontestablement l'État a mis les
moyens à Marseille notamment des
renforts de policiers on est à plus de
300 vous savez ce qui se passe à
Marseille c'est qu'on est en train de
déstabiliser les trafics de drogue d'où
la recrudescence de ces actes ignobles
l'angle mort de la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron sur sur ce sujet c'est la justice
j'avais il y a quelques semaines
quelques mois de cela proposant un grand
plan de lutte contre la drogue sur
Marseille avec 4 5 mesures fortes
la première étant de s'interroger sur le
durcissement des peines mettre des
peines plancher des peines
incompressibles notamment pour les
dealers pour les têtes de réseau j'avais
proposé 30 ans un compromis pour en fait
que la sanction soit dissuasive la
deuxième aspect c'est l'exécut
l'exécution des peines l'effectivité
n'est pas là encore on a une politique
pénale qui n'est pas en adéquation avec
la violence de la société pourquoi parce
qu'on regarde la peau des typologues
sous le prisme du manque de place de
prison donc le troisième élément c'est
la construction de place de prison et
puis il y a un aspect qu'il faut
développer c'est par rapport aux
consommateurs si à trafic c'est parce
qu'il y a des consommateurs
pour parler de l'agent l'amende pardon
forfaitaire délictuels je pense qu'il
faut l'augmenter un peu en cas de
récidive des obligations de soins me
paraissent obligatoire et puis dernier
point une large campagne d'informations
comme on avait fait en 19890 pour la
violence routière la sécurité routière
il faut dire à nos jeunes dès le plus
jeune âge au collège au lycée attention
la drogue c'est comme l'alcool ça vous
détruit on va parler de la location de
rentrée scolaire faut-il revoir ses
modalités d'attribution c'est ce que
vous souhaitez faire vous avez préparé
une proposition de loi sur le sujet elle
expulsar vient nous la détailler
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Ariane bonjour
Stéphane le ridulier bonjour et Alex
avec ce texte Stéphane le rugulier veut
s'attaquer au détournement de la
location d'entre vous effectivement
alors on le rappelle l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire a été versée cette
année à 3 millions de familles sous
conditions de ressources cela représente
un montant entre 398 euros et 434 euros
par enfant et c'est à location et bien
elle doit servir à supporter les
dépenses nécessaires dans une rentrée
scolaire mais depuis des années et bien
certains dénoncent une mauvaise
utilisation de cet allocation de la part
des familles écoutez ce qu'on disait
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale Jean-Michel Blanquer c'était
il y a deux ans
si on regarde des choses en face que
parfois il y a des achats d'écran plat
plus important au mois de septembre qui
a d'autres moments donc bien sûr que ce
qu'il peut y avoir qu'on peut regarder
ça cette façon là donc des bons d'achat
ça peut être intéressant et justement
Stéphane Le rudelier avec votre
proposition de loi et bien vous remettez
sur la table cette idée de transformer
la location de rentrée scolaire en bon
d'achat pour être sûr que soit bien
utilisé votre votre texte prévoit
spécifiquement que chaque famille
recevra un titre spécial de paiement
personnel et nominatif dénommé bon de
rentrée scolaire valable pour la période
d'utilisation dont il fait mention et
seulement auprès de prestataires agréés
et puis votre proposition de loi un
store un justificatif de scolarité
obligatoire qui doit être présenté pour
chaque enfant y compris pour ceux entre
16 et 18 ans âge auquel l'école n'est
plus obligatoire et aujourd'hui seule
une attestation sur l'honneur et
nécessaire pour obtenir la location
d'entrée scolaire
n'a pas manqué de faire réagir la gauche
du Sénat oui regardez par exemple ce
qu'en pense la sénatrice écologiste
Mélanie Vogel elle estime que ce texte
n'a pas sa place sur le bureau du Sénat
je la cite à l'heure où des enfants ne
mangent pas à leur faim ou de plus en
plus de gens se présentent au resto du
coeur ou la droite refuse toutes les
propositions pour agir sur l'inflation
cette proposition n'est pas descente et
puis on peut se demander s'il y a un
véritable détournement de la location de
rentrer scolaire c'est difficile à
prouver les études sont assez anciennes
et des montres plutôt le contraire la
dernière enquête menée par la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales c'était en 2013
et à l'affirmait que 95% des familles
concernées avaient à l'époque utilisé
cet allocation pour acheter tout
simplement des fournitures et des
vêtements Stéphane laudulier qu'est-ce
que vous répondez aux critiques de la
gauche sur votre texte qui estime que ce
texte est bien stigmatise les plus
pauvres de notre pays l'idée je pense
que Mélanie vosgienne n'a pas pas lu la
proposition de loi l'idée n'est pas de
remettre en cause cette allocation
rentrée c'est que avoir la garantie
qu'elle soit utilisée par rapport aux
finalités et aux objectifs qu'elle porte
c'est quand même des deniers publics et
moi je pense aux enfants comme vous
dites il y a 95% mais il y a quand même
5% des parents donc certains enfants qui
ne bénéficient pas de cette allocution
de rentrée de rentrée scolaire notamment
pour des fournitures scolaires pour des
vêtements pour un équipement sportif
cette mesure là elle permet c'est
l'école c'est la notion de l'école de la
République à ce que tous les enfants
puissent avoir un minimum une égalité
des chances quand elle rentre quand il
rentre
en classe si il y a un détournement même
s'il est mineur ça veut dire vous
pénalisez des centaines de milliers
d'enfants puisque c'est quand même des
millions qui bénéficient de cette
allocation donc j'estime vous savez
c'est comme à l'image des tickets
restaurants ça ne fait pas bondir
personne d'avoir ces bons spéciaux où on
est sûr que ça sera pour nos enfants je
pense que c'est l'honneur aussi de
l'école de la République alors dans les
5% cités par l'enquête de la caisse
d'allocation familiale en 2013 alors ce
n'est pas forcément un détournement ça
pourrait être pour d'autres dépenses qui
sont inhérentes à la rentrée scolaire
que les fournitures et les vêtements
est-ce que vous comprenez pour que pour
ces familles qui ont des ressources
modestes et bien ça peut être
stigmatisant une proposition la
proposition de loi ne focalise pas
uniquement sur les fournitures scolaires
il y a un spectre quand même assez large
de prestataires agréés et de de bien ou
de consommation courante donc c'est pas
restrictif par exemple qu'est-ce qui
pourrait acheter les parents avec eux ça
peut être du matériel notamment
informatique pour pour l'enfant ça peut
ça peut être des vêtements on l'a dit
mais aussi des équipements sportifs des
des baskets tout doit être concentré
tourné vers l'enfant donc attention
parce que même le ministre l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale le
disait effectivement si on utilise ces
400 euros pour aller acheter un écran
plat je ne vois pas trop le rapport avec
la scolarisation de l'enfant donc au
moins ce dispositif elle mérite de
cibler les achats qui sont nécessaires à
l'éducation de l'enfant et justement
est-ce qu'on a des données solides pour
prouver aujourd'hui en 2023 que cette
allocation elle sert à acheter des
télévisions on a on a déjà il y a 10 ans
donc il faudrait peut-être relancer une
enquête mais il y a 10 ans on avait
quand même 5 %
de de parents qui n'utilisaient pas
directement pour l'éducation de l'enfant
et ça ça me ça me gêne énormément
puisque c'est la finalité puis le
deuxième aspect c'est s'assurer quand
même que l'enfant notamment pour les
16-18 ans et bel et bien intégré dans le
cursus scolaire parce que là aussi une
attestation sur l'honneur je préférais
moins un certificat de ce scolarité d'un
établissement qu'une attestation sur
l'honneur donc finalement ce texte il
demande des garanties sur l'utilisation
de cette allocation sociale est-ce que
ce n'est pas aussi un symbole politique
un marqueur de droite que vous arborez
en cette rentrée marqueur de droite en
tout cas c'est tout à l'heure on parlait
de la dépense publique
c'est là une bonne utilisation en tout
état de cause des données publiques pour
être sûr que la mesure qui est la plus
légitime possible par rapport à
l'égalité des chances des enfants soit
bel et bien appliquer pour 100% des
familles françaises merci Alex à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure
Macron et ce sera évidemment à suivre
dans le club merci à la crête à tout à
l'heure on va terminer en parlant de
votre partie et de vous Stéphane Le
rugulier vous étiez à la rentrée
politique de Gérald Darmanin à Tourcoing
fin août pourquoi c'est un premier pas
vers un aliment du côté de la majorité
totalement trans partisane je répondu à
l'invitation de Gérard darmin qui est un
ami je suis native du Nord pour tout
vous dire j'étais dans le Nord au moment
de sa rentrée politique puis je pense
que c'est bien aussi de débattre avec
ceux qui n'ont partage pas totalement
les mêmes idées vous savez c'était un
sujet qui me tenait à cœur il a voulu
faire sa rentrée politique par rapport
au classe populaire et moi il y a un an
et demi quand j'ai pris la tête de la
fédération des Bouches-du-Rhône j'avais
été interviewée par l'un de vos
confrères et j'avais dit vous savez la
droite il y a un mâle c'est qu'on a
perdu le lien avec les classes
populaires et ça avait été la Une de ma
rentrée oui sur ce sujet là il peut
permettre à la droite de renouer ce lien
avec les classes populaires
on verra en temps et en heure de toute
façon il y aura une recomposition
d'espace politique on le sait bien que
Emmanuel Macron ne se représentant plus
il faudra recomposer la droite
républicaine j'espère que ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que d'anciennes
personnalité de votre famille Gérald
Darmanin Édouard Philippe ont vocation
à les rejoindre je suis pas moi je
préférais qu'il s'anit avec nous parce
que je suis allé je reste à l'air et
j'aimerais qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui
puisse rassembler de chez nous la droite
républicaine mais ne fermons pas
les portes ne nous recroveillons pas sur
nous-mêmes clairement nous sommes un
parti du gouvernement on est plus aux
heures de l'UMP des républicains d'antan
si j'ose dire donc cette recomposition
il faut parler tout le monde il faut
avoir un dialogue permanent et puis
faire revenir aux électeurs parce que ça
veut dire que pour survivre les
républicains devront tôt ou tard
s'allier avec la majorité présidentielle
j'ai jamais vu la partie politique seul
gagné une élection présidentielle
c'était vrai pour le RPR c'était vrai
pour l'UDF il y a toujours eu un moment
donné un grand rassemblement au niveau
de la droite ou de la gauche c'est
pareil donc ayons cela l'esprit ne
regardons pas dans le rétroviseur ne
soyons pas figés en 2017 il y a eu des
annonces d'opportunités au niveau de la
macronie on le voit bien cette
distension entre l'aile gauche et l'aile
droite je pense que Édouard Philippe
Bruno Le Maire et gendarman sont
fondamentalement de droite même si ils
ont eu un parcours différent du mien
mais voilà en plus à même de rassembler
et de vous faire revenir au gouvernement
que Laurent Wauquiez par exemple
ça on verra vous savez on est à 4 ans 3
ans et demi de l'élection présidentielle
il faudra en capacité d'avoir un
candidat pour l'instant on travaille sur
le fond
c'est essentiel il faut un nouveau
corpus idéologique il faut qu'on lance
des débats sur des thèmes comme ça peut
être les classes populaires moi je
parlais des classes populaires et de
l'autorité quand j'étais à Tourcoing
parce que
ça se peut se faire c'est les premières
victimes du délitement de l'autorité ça
j'ai voulu insister là dessus c'était
maternatal mais au-delà de ça quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
extrêmes avec la montée du harnais
encore eu un sondage ira assez alarmant
par rapport au rassemblement national on
a une responsabilité on a un devoir de
rassemblement qui va qui ira au-delà de
notre famille politique on doit d'abord
travailler en interne et après s'ouvrir
vers l'extérieures puisque ça arrive
c'est dans moins d'un an Marion maréchal
et candidate pour reconquête c'est une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour les
républicains
des uns et des autres il faudra que nous
ayons
un projet européen
qui sortent en fait des sentiers battus
et qui ne soient pas en fait
un mix entre la macronie et et
monsieur Zemmour donc on est en train
d'y réfléchir on est en train de poser
les bases d'un projet europ éen après il
faudra choisir la tête la tête de liste
vous savez la campagne est encore est
encore loin même si déjà des parties
sont dans les starting blocks
la médecine de notre invité